et depuis plusieurs jours un conflit
oppose des groupes TF1 et Canal+ je sais
pas si vous avez suivi le sujet du
conflit la distribution des chaînes
c'est à la suite de ce conflit c'est
très simple puisque en fait je vous
explique
pour avoir TF1 et des autres chaînes du
groupe TF1 sur mycanal il fallait que
Canal paye 15 millions d'euros voilà
pour des chaînes gratuites sur la TNT
donc c'est vrai qu'à un moment voilà le
groupe Canal+ s'est posé la question et
on le comprend tout à fait et donc ils
ont essayé de négocier avec TF1 TF1
n'est dit non il y a pas de négociation
c'est ou 15 millions rien c'est aussi de
faire des négociations mais c'est un
petit peu ils ont dit non donc canal a
dit bon bah puisque c'est comme ça et
ben on arrête et on va en diffuse plus
TF1 et les autres chaînes du groupe
malheureusement ça fait plus de mal à
TF1 que le canal et donc les animateurs
de TF1 ce sont mobilisés pour faire une
petite vidéo regarde depuis le 2
septembre le groupe Canal+ a décidé de
couper la diffusion de l'ensemble des
chaînes du groupe TF1 grand nombre de
Français de nos programmes et nous le
déplorons sincèrement si habituellement
vous receviez nos chaînes et MyTF1 via
Canal+ mycanal ou une parabole tel fait
ça que vous voulez vous informer vous
divertir vivre les plus grandes
compétitions sportives c'est votre droit
et il y a des solutions flasher dès
maintenant ce QR code ou aller sur notre
site TF1 et vous et suivez toutes les
indications pour retrouver TF1 et tous
vos programmes alors voilà
merci merci
depuis plusieurs jours donc ce conflit
ferrage ce que ça fonctionne ce sont les
téléspectateurs bien entendu mais c'est
vrai que moi je comprends et c'est
normal je suis dans le canapé je
défendrai toujours mon groupe et en plus
je comprends tout à fait leur position
sur des chaînes qu'on a gratuitement sur
la TNT pourquoi
pour avoir des chaînes comme TF1 TF1
série film ou encore TFX et nous avec
les chroniqueurs nous aussi on a fait
une vidéo pour vous mobiliser
depuis le 2 septembre le groupe Canal+ a
décidé de couper la diffusion des
chaînes du groupe TF1
après que le groupe TF1 est demandé 15
millions d'euros groupes Canal+ pour des
chaînes qui sont gratuites sur la TNT
privant les Français d'un grand nombre
de leurs programmes comme la Villa des
cœurs brisés masque singer
good singer chef sur TMC stéréo club
visuel suspect ou encore marblemania de
ce fait nous demandons expressément au
groupe Canal+ de ne surtout pas rétablir
la diffusion des chaînes du groupe TF1
et si par hasard vous voulez voir des
programmes de TF1 qui marchent
rendez-vous tous les jeudis sur C8 avec
il y a que la vérité qui compte à très
bientôt à très bientôt et à bientôt les
gars on n'aurait pas oublié le 6 à 7
avec Casta is the cover vous avez fait
là mais c'est chez nous ça Cyril ah
merde tu es chez nous ça
c'est la tuile ça ça part sur TF1 ça
c'est bon pour eux
merci à vous merci
après bien sûr on espère que ça va
s'arranger pour les téléspectateurs
c'est vrai que voilà moi je voulais
regarder voilà TF1 ce week-end parce que
je regarde mon ami Jean-Luc Reichmann
voilà quand même un pote et j'arrive pas
à le voir voilà donc j'ai dû l'appeler
tout ça je dis comment ça va ça me
suffit je te vois plus voilà mais bon
moi j'ai acheté un thé donc je le
regarde en fait donc voilà c'est un fou
c'est un faux problème